hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to well
there's no doubt about it
theme songs played a huge part in our
childhoods they were fun clever
enjoyable and catchy as hell in fact a
lot of these songs still stay hidden in
the darkest corners of our memory just
waiting for inopportune moments to
spring out of our heads and ruin our
concentration so that's why today I'm
paying tribute to the top 11 best
nostalgic songs ever why top 11 because
I like to go one step beyond so sit back
and enjoy the top 11 catches nostalgic
themes
you
number 11 for many of us Sesame Street
was the first show we ever saw and the
only figures that the theme song will be
as irritatingly catchy as the lessons it
teaches us
my only problem with this song is that
they never don't tell Yannick gets a
Sesame Street I mean where the hell is
it is it in Brooklyn Chicago New York
how do you get to this damn place
wherever the hell it is it made for a
really great song and the perfect
beginning for our countdown number 10 oh
god I hate this song I think most people
do but it doesn't matter once you hear
that a matches synthesizer in the
opening you're going to be humming this
crap for the rest of your life what is
that thing anyhow
dude if every book played this song when
I opened it up I would never read again
still you can't fault the song for being
so damn catchy or the fact that it was
the only show that actually made us want
to read Forks with that said Reading
Rainbow is the perfect placement for the
number 10 spot number 9 this character
was so popular that she actually got two
hit shows with two kid theme songs one
was a game show where the entire theme
song was played acapella dope and the
other was a cartoon show with a
full-fledged choir singing all the way
through
I think the game show one is a little
big catch here but the cartoon deserves
an honorable mention and when you're
doing a show that's trying to be
educational you sure as hell better
write something that our short attention
spans can remember whichever one you
like better Carmen Sandiego definitely
knew how to keep up good song in RS
number eight yeah not only did this show
have a great song but it also had a
kick-ass opening as well I mean look at
that animation how can you not be hyped
after watching this opening with the
rock guitar female singers and fast
paced feet Thundercats had us all ready
for action in fact maybe did it a little
too well I mean as soon as the show
started the characters never move - like
in the opening I mean look at this but
barely moving a muscle do something now
well but that said the opening song did
a great job of hiking us up so good that
we didn't care the opening was better
than the show half the time but some
great animation and great tunes
Thundercats is easily too
number seven all right as much as I hate
this show I have to admit I really do
love this easel it was the only thing I
even look forward to whenever their show
came on and when the song ended so that
my tolerance for the show but let's face
it it's a cool song with its fast-paced
kick-ass guitar and lyrics that are
pretty easy to remember if the show
loved the song but hey that's Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers crap
number six ah yes
you can't think all America without
thinking GI Joe and their song was the
keenest Central American feat it was big
triumphant and one of the few theme
songs that actually had counterpoint
melodies which means you always needed
another kid to help you sing it
this is back in the day when the worst
terrorist we had to deal with was Cobra
ah goddess Cobra what he threatened us
it was funny when the real terrorists
threaten us is just creepy
when we heard that Victoria's theme we
all knew we'd be okay why because the
iconic man GI Joe
a real American feet
number five another song that
practically seemed all-american was
Transformers true the guitar was great
the theme was memorable and the
animation was cool but by far the best
part was hearing that robotic voice a
Jesus I could hear that all day oh and
don't think we weren't pissed when the
song wasn't in the recent live action
I saw people actually wait until the end
of the credits to hear the song when we
get nothing the fucking sequel that are
in this song in fact you could probably
use that for good marketing you can
actually call the film Transformers -
yes this one actually has the theme song
I guaranteed ticket sales would go
through the roof
why because this song is that fucking
good transformers it's more than geeks
the Year number four
you think with all the lyrics in the
world the hardest ones to put to music
with the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
but surprisingly they turn this totally
insane title into one hell of a great
song I mean every kid in the world knew
this song and got hyped up whenever we
heard it but just like the Thundercats
opening it never looked quite as good as
the opening credits I mean here's the
opening and now here's the actual show I
mean do they look anything alike I think
most of these shows through all their
time and energy into the openings
because they do that once they hooked us
in we'd probably be too lazy to change
the channel
luckily Ninja Turtles kicked ass and I
had kick-ass song to go with it although
I don't think turtle power ever became a
popular phrase no matter how much they
try to force it down my throat
still Ninja Turtles was the shit and so
is the theme song making these heroes in
a half-shell number 4 on the countdown
the Glee anything by the Richard stone
team for those of you who don't know
Richard stow is a composer and
songwriter in the 80s and 90s he hit the
big time with Steven Spielberg asked him
to do the music and song for some water
Brothers cartoons he was producing and
the rest is history
Richard stone and his team put together
some of the cleverest and catchy theme
songs that ever hit TV remember this
timeless classic how about this one
comin to baby your comfort of a video
and of course the always hot ok-hee and
the brain is me
the brain stones team didn't just do
theme songs though they did all the
music for the shows every little melody
every musical segue and the only song in
the world that actually made you want to
learn geography United States Canada
Mexico Panama Haiti Jamaica Peru
Republic Dominican Cuba Carribean
Greenland El Salvador do I mean if
everyone tried to learn this songs I can
never get it down anyone that made you
actually try to educate yourself without
you even knowing it it's doing something
right
sadly Richard stone lost his life to
pancreatic cancer in 2001 leaving a
legacy of great music behind luckily he
is survived by these incredible tunes
with great music fantastic lyrics and
ingenious writing Richard stones team is
more than eligible for the number 3 spot
number 2
talk about a song short on lyrics the
Inspector Gadget song has a total of
five words in the entire thing Inspector
Gadget go and woohoo and yet they still
manage to make this one of the catchiest
songs that children ever heard so how
can a song with almost no lyrics stay
fresh in our heads for so long I don't
know it just does why the opening
credits are great it's the closing
credits I always look forward to because
that's where you hear dr. quass a get
you next time gadget next and not
forgetting the whole song kind of sounds
like an 80s computer booting up but for
some reason you can't get an element
it's a weird love-hate relationship we
have with some songs kind of like demo I
mean you know it was really weird but
for some reason that always stays in
your head why for whatever reason
Inspector Gadget isn't leaving us
anytime soon if you manage to forget
about this song right after you hear it
consider yourself dehumanized and the
number one catchiest nostalgic theme
song is
oh god damn this song from the minute
you hear it it is never gonna lead your
head
this song tormented so many children I
can't even explain you think you're
trying to answer the questions on your
math test but no all you're thinking
about is you think you're playing
basketball with your teammates but no
all you're thinking about is you think
you're about to achieve enlightenment
the pearly gates of knowledge are
opening up and all the secrets of the
universe are about to be revealed
now think about it it will never leave
it will never leave it's like an
addiction think you're over it you think
I only know a few lyrics on the song uh
what is it on life is like a hurricane
here in duck burn racecars lazers
aeroplanes it's a duck blur might solve
a mystery or rewrite history ducktales
woohoo every day that I've been making
duck tales woohoo tan cetera you can do
duck tales fit the danger lurks behind
you there's a stranger out to find you
what to do is just grab on to some
doctors Wow
I mean once you hear it once it will
never ever go away and you know that
creepy thing is I think this show stayed
on the air strictly because of the theme
song how do you think about it what do
you actually remember about this show
I remember screwed his nephews a pilot
who crashed a lot is it
I don't remember goddamn other thing
about this show this show literally kept
bringing us back simply because of the
song it is that powerful so now that
you've heard the catch is nostalgic song
of all time
tell the people one them don't let them
hear the song because once it gets into
your head it buries its way into your
brain
festering festering until it blooms into
a gigantic ball of human waste that will
eat you alive were the people the V Baha
I'm in the sour cream I remember it so
you don't have to
let's go